this is a little compilation of if you
like your plan you can keep it you can
keep your plan if you are satisfied with
it if you like the plane you have you
can keep it if you like your plan and
you like your doctor you won't have to
do a thing you keep your plan if you
like your health care plan you will be
able to keep your health care plan if
you've got health insurance you can keep
it if you like your health care plan you
will keep your plan if you've got health
insurance do you like your doctor you
like your plan you can keep your doctor
you can keep your plan if you have
insurance that you like then you will be
able to keep that insurance if you like
your doctor or healthcare plan you can
keep them if you like your health care
plan you can keep your health care plan
okay so there are many many many more
examples of that that was actually just
clips from 2009 as you probably saw
alright so we're starting with two lies
here I guess do you consider this one a
lie though because they're saying that
this isn't a lie that that's really what
he thought from the beginning it's not a
lie and it's really stupid to equate to
two lies I mean they're nothing similar
and this is what frustrates me all the
time about the media saying well
everybody lies the left lies or right
light whether different kinds of lies
and this is like a marketing tactic that
went awry and it's hard to explain a
2,000 page Obama care act in a quick
convenient you know radio spot or TV
spot so they want simplicity and said
you can keep your plan if you like it
with instead of say you probably feel
like it unless one of these 18 different
qualifiers come to play in which case
these 47 other things coming to play in
which case another hundred things come
into play and then it's a muddle
complicated message it's not a big deal
and should he have maybe said it a
little bit more I don't know maybe he
should equivocated a bit more instead
there are you know conditions and other
Turner conditions that might come into
play right but that just invites you
know right a whole new category then it
would spend the whole time after he gave
that speech everybody the round table at
CNN reckon the whole time
talking about that little thing he said
but that what about those people who can
so you exactly so what he so was a
technical inaccuracies I think that's
the word it was a marketing ploy he was
a sentiment selling something so I agree
it's not necessary it's not a bold-faced
absolute lie because he was doing what
he had to do to get the things sold but
shouldn't we hold him to a slightly
higher account than that no I was just
cuz the the the dialogue is so stupid I
CNN round table we got caught up I'm
really okay you know what I hey you know
I don't give President Obama a pass on
anything I'll give him a pass on this
because first of all the people who are
criticizing him for saying that the
reason why he had to say that was so
that he could sell that plan which the
majority of people can keep their
goddamn plans and if you lose your plan
you're gonna get a better plan so it's
it's so he was lying hey I'm like I said
you're gonna get one scoop ice cream you
get to you know I mean that's the kind
of like he did just now right so uh I
don't think those are the same cut that
those are the same kind of lies and the
people who are criticizing him the
hardest for that the reason why he had
to do this and sell this plan give you a
plan that you might is because that's
the plan that they came up with because
they won't let us have our plan which is
single-payer we want single-payer Barack
Obama would implement it except those
other [ __ ] won't let us have it
so he has to implement their plan he
does and they still [ __ ] on it right and
irony of course is that system was
broken in the first place and we're
already paying for all the people that
go to the emergency room and as you know
losing their health insurance anyway we
were talking about the private market
for us those people get lose their plans
all the time every year they have to get
a new plan uh yes the problem with
Obamacare is is twofold one Reba a
pro-obama folks have to stop pretending
like this is some sort of great curaga
panacea like holy [ __ ] now now we have
Obamacare great vigor be so awesome
that's not true and on the flip side the
other problem is that people are opposed
to have to stop pretending that this is
the POC ellipse Obamacare will destroy
this like sex slavery yeah it's like the
Holocaust yeah like it's neither one of
those things it's like a small movement
from what we had before to a slightly
better system where now we have
previously uninsured people with
insurance and you know you can't deny
people frequently uninsurable be right
and now right here right and it's a
small marginal improvement with some
marginal downsides calm down everyone
calm down yeah I I think that's the
point people need to hear more yeah and
I think the part that I see slightly
different is the part about the sales
thing I'm not so sure I believe that the
ends justify the means always so in my
state in this case he was selling
something that he probably knew wasn't
exactly the truth and I get the
marketing part of it I get you had to do
it but we all sort of expected better
than it better from him i guess probably
five years ago or six years ago now we
don't anymore I guess that's the part
yet Nelly disappointed you know I don't
see this as a like vicious malicious lie
I see this as a lie to get us into a war
yeah right I see this likely this as
like a bad marketing job by people who
came up with a system that's not all
that great but they're trying to pitch
it as one yeah so I think might to me
the better lies or the lies that kind of
pissed me off this year were all the
lies that John Kerry kept telling about
Syria and he would do it with such
indignation such righteous indignation
and if you disagree with him then you
this these are indisputable facts yes oh
you son of a [ __ ] well i'm pretty sure
that the three of us were the most
anti-war people i think you're right tyt
which in retrospect now you know Kerri
kept saying this is Hitler Assad yeah
well now we've done nothing about Hitler
so it with you yeah well it Hitler go
Pericles predators okay fine if he would
Hitler was willing to negotiate a little
bit right then no prob woulda been okay
with right yeah just so bad by the way
let's say yeah we were right we were
right about Syria to no need to go to
war in Syria need to drop one hundred
million dollars worth of bombs in Syria
and kill a bunch of people because
what's that what's that saying there's
no flag big enough that could cover the
shame of murdering innocents
you